ein bisschen hoffnung haben wir uns
heute alle gemacht dass merkel in ihrem
statement heute kurz vor ostern
ankündigen wird das die korona maßnahmen
im land gelockert werden aber nichts
davon in ihrem statement heute will ich
das jetzt so benennen kann dann will ich
nicht verhehlen das sage ich jetzt
gerade noch mal vor ostern dass ich zu
beginn vor noch gar nicht so langer zeit
oft besorgt war bei dem sehr schnellen
anstieg den wir gesehen haben ob wir
unsere maßnahmen nicht vielleicht noch
verschärfen müssen ob das was wir
vereinbart haben ausreicht oder ob es
und so geht wie in einigen unserer
nachbarländer dass man noch einmal
verschärften maßnahmen einsetzen muss
und deshalb sage ich dass wir darüber
schon sehr froh sein können dass das
vielleicht zum jetzigen zeitpunkt kann
man das sagen nicht notwendig ist und
deshalb bedeutet das aber andersherum
auch wir dürfen uns nicht in sicherheit
wiegen sondern müssen wirklich froh sein
dass deutlichere einschränkung um
vielleicht nicht notwendig sind und das
heißt für mich wir dürfen jetzt nicht
leichtsinnig sein
wir dürfen uns nicht in sicherheit
wiegen und ich kenne das auch von mir
persönlich man hat ein bisschen hoffnung
dann gewinnt man zutrauen dann ist man
innerlich etwas entspannter und schon
ist man auch ein bisschen leichtsinnig
nein wir müssen konzentriert bleiben die
lage ist fragil
der chef des robert koch instituts hat
gerade wieder gesagt es gibt keinen
grund für entspannung und wir müssen
dies über ostern über die tage danach
weiter so fortsetzen denn wir können uns
sehr sehr schnell das zerstören was wir
jetzt erreicht haben das heißt also
konzentration disziplin das ist das was
fürsorge für die nächsten ist fürsorge
für die nächsten durch abstand so weit
also bundeskanzlerin angela merkel sie
hat dazu aufgerufen auch jetzt während
der osterfeiertage weiterhin auf die
maßnahmen zu achten bei mir im studio
jetzt unser bild vize paul ronzheimer
paul war diese oster ansprache sag jetzt
mal eine enttäuschung für dich eine
enttäuschung würde ich nicht sagen das
war die erwartbaren aussagen von angela
merkel sie sagt ganz klar es geht hier
weiter um menschenleben und es geht uns
darum jeden mensch und die maßnahmen
müssen weitergehen sie hat es gelöst mit
einer art kommunikativen trick sie
wusste ja dass darüber debattiert wird
ob wir maßnahmen lockern sie hat gesagt
wir können froh sein dass wir nicht noch
mehr maßnahmen brauchen wie zum beispiel
in frankreich oder anderen
nachbarländern ist der fall ist aber
wenn man jetzt gehofft hatte dass sie in
irgendeiner form auf die debatte eingeht
was maßnahmen angeht da kann man sagen
für diejenigen ist es sicherlich eine
enttäuschung
es gibt jetzt in der politik ganz
unterschiedliche aussagen darüber wie
lange diese maßnahmen jetzt noch wie
streng bleiben müssen wie kann das sein
also auf der einen seite mehr merken auf
der anderen seite ministerpräsident
laschet wie kann das sein dass die
politik sich so uneinig darüber ist ja
ich glaube das ist absolut katastrophal
was da in der kommunikation passiert
denn gerade in unsicheren zeiten wollen
die menschen klarheit und diese klarheit
gibt es nicht wir müssen uns das so
vorstellen heute morgen sind die
menschen aufgewacht mit den nachrichten
dass es nach den osterferien vielleicht
besser werden könnte
kurz danach kam nrw-ministerpräsident
armin laschet und hat gesagt wir
brauchen jetzt ein plan zum hochfahren
und dann roms kam die kanzlerin und hat
gesagt nein
die debatte will sie nicht und sie hat
ein klares machtwort gesprochen und das
ist natürlich auch im zeichen an armin
laschet moment mal ich bin die kanzlerin
ich entscheide aber was die menschen
dort draußen sehen ist dass man sich
uneinig in der politik ist und das ist
glaube ich in diesen zeiten schlecht